joe biden flails in a friendly town hall
with cnn's anderson cooper the virginia
gubernatorial race comes down to the
wire and the national institutes of
health admit funding gain of function
research i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with a vpn so should
you visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first let me remind you you
are paying way too much for your cell
phone bill because you think you have to
have one of the big guys right in order
to have the great coverage of verizon at
t or t mobile what if you could get the
same exact coverage as one of the big
guys but pay a lot less money this is
where pure talk usa comes in pure talk
doesn't charge you for any of the crap
the big companies charge you for right
their retail stores their overhead and
all that pure talk instead gives you
killer 5g coverage on the same 5g
network as one of the big guys for about
half the cost the average family is
saving over 800 a year just by making
the switch so what exactly is your
excuse i already made the switch you can
keep your number keep your phone or get
huge discounts on latest iphones and
androids get a limited talk text and six
gigs of data for just 30 bucks a month
and listen if you still want unlimited
data you can still get it and save a
fortune go to puretalk.com shop for a
plan that's right for you they have a
30-day risk-free guarantee so you
literally have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com enter promo code shapiro
you'll save 50
off your very first month of coverage
that's puretalk.com promo code shapiro
puretalk is simply smarter wireless go
check them out right now alrighty so
virginia is now down to the wire and
democrats are deeply upset about it the
polls are showing it is neck and neck
between glenn young the republican in
that race and terry mcauliffe the former
virginia governor and head of the dnc
mcauliffe should have been running away
with this race remember that hillary
clinton won this state going away joe
biden won this state going away and now
you've got a neck and neck race between
glenn young who's a pretty traditional
republican and terry mcauliffe who's a
normally traditional democrat this
should be a walk over which is why james
carville the
semi-centrist democrat analyst he's
saying he's deeply worried about what's
going on in virginia and they should be
we're in a very tight race
and democrats need to be activated uh i
do think that that trump is a is a has a
tug against yonkin i i've seen a lot of
research on that of course he said he
wouldn't be running without trump then
he tries to run away from him
he's kind of slippery but
uh yeah it's close there's no doubt
about it and i'm scared to death
and and as i and other democrats should
be
okay what carville is pointing out here
is that all of the attempts to tie young
kin to trump have failed and that is why
junkin is doing well right now all of
the polls show that he is neck and neck
with mcauliffe and the reason for that
is because people are focusing on the
bread and butter issues suburban moms
are focusing in on the failures of
education in the state of virginia and
it's not just about the virginia
gubernatorial race according to politico
the virginia house is up for grabs as
well quote alex askew knows firsthand
how tight elections can get for
democrats in virginia he barely won his
seat in the state house of delegates
defeating his republican opponent by 802
votes in 2019. that's why askew is
campaigning furiously ahead of the
november election on the first sunday of
souls to the polls early voting over the
weekend askew 36 attended two church
services before an afternoon of campaign
events and canvassing he was joined by a
colleague state delegate nancy guy who
clinched her seat by an even closer
margin of just 40 votes when virginia
voters cast their ballots in two weeks
they're not just weighing in on a
closely watched governor's election one
that's been hyped as a bellwether ahead
of the 2022 midterms and a judgment on
president joe biden they're also
deciding whether to keep legislative
democrats in office a choice that will
determine how much statewide power the
party will yield and reveal voter
satisfaction with the crush of
progressive laws enacted in the last two
years remember virginia when it went
blue started immediately pushing very
radical measures that a large percentage
of virginians didn't like everything
from gun control to transgender
bathrooms virginia might become
increasingly blue at the presidential
level but democrats only came to control
both chambers of the state legislature
in 2019 after nearly two decades of
mostly republican control and next month
they could lose control of both the
governor's mansion and the house all in
one day
it is a it is a disaster for democrats
because they overshot the mark democrats
have a nasty habit of taking power and
then believing that their entire radical
mandate has now been approved by the
voters that is not true democrats spent
the last two years passing a long list
of sweeping policies they implemented
criminal justice reform legalized
marijuana expanded voting rights raised
the minimum wage enacted gun control
repealed the death penalty and set a
goal of getting virginia electric
utilities to 100 renewable generation by
state house democrats have raised almost
twice as much money as the republicans
but they're still struggling
and there's a real problem and one of
the reasons it's a real problem is
because the battle between parents and
teachers is growing extraordinarily
serious in loudoun county particularly a
shocking story out of wtop.com
today remember we reported at daily wire
the news
that the that there was a an alleged
sexual assault in a bathroom
at a loudoun county public school
and the parent of the daughter in that
particular case then went to a school
board meeting where one of the
superintendents of the school board said
that there had been no such assault on
record in a bathroom anywhere well now
it turns out that that guy was just
lying according to an email uncovered
the superintendent of loudoun county
public schools did send a brief
confidential email to school board
members on may 28th the same day a
female student at stonebridge high
school said she was sexually assaulted
in a bathroom in an email provided to
wtop by the school system superintendent
scott zigler alerted the board that the
loudoun county sheriff's office was
investigating the incident but provided
few details
the purpose of this email is to provide
you with information regarding an
incident that occurred at stonebridge
high school this afternoon a female
student alleged that a male student
sexually assaulted her in a restroom the
lcso is investigating the matter
according to ziggler last week ziegler
apologized for the school system's
reaction to recent sexual assaults by
students and outline steps he said would
improve the system going forward that
assault was not made public until the
victim's father told the daily wire that
the same 15 year old charged in the
daughter's attack was later charged with
groping a different girl at broadrun
high school on october 6th
louden county commonwealth attorneys
buddha bibaraj told wtop the same 15
year old has been charged in both crimes
but said the boy was on pre-trial
electronic monitoring for the may 28
sexual assault when he was charged with
sexual battery and abduction for the
october incident
remember ziegler had said in public
that they had no record of anybody being
assaulted in a bathroom
bill stanley the attorney representing
the family said in a statement ziggler's
comments confirmed what the family
already believed that the school's board
and administration failed to provide a
safe environment for their child
this has become a gubernatorial issue of
course because the the republican
candidate junkin has been accusing the
county of a cover-up and noting that the
school system run by the teachers unions
has been doing a poor job of protecting
students and failing to indoctrinate
them as well
in a thursday statement lcps said it was
releasing ziggler's email after it
received a number of questions from
community members regarding it and
and if and when the school board was
made aware of the alleged sexual assault
the school board was not provided
specific details or the names of those
involved and were advised by dr zigler
they would not be that they would not
receive updates regarding this matter as
it was being investigated by the loudoun
county sheriff's office
so the big question is why zigler
answered no to a school board member's
question about whether he was aware of
sexual assaults in school bathrooms
zigler said he wrongly interpreted the
question as incidents involving
transgender and gender fluid students
since the questions moments earlier had
been about the county's transgender
policy but if the entire line of
questioning was about whether girls are
at higher risk if boys can come into the
bathroom
then that seems like a relevant
consideration
[Music]
so people are going to lose their jobs
over this as well they should
meanwhile in an attempt to fight back
terry mcauliffe is activating the
teachers unions not only are the
teachers unions actually
cutting ads on behalf of terry mcauliffe
in virginia
it turns out that the teachers unions
are now using public dollars in order to
stump for terry mcauliffe there's no
other way to interpret what is happening
in for example richmond according to
wwbt an enrichment public school direct
update on wednesday evening
superintendent jason cameras said the
division will be closing school
additional days the first week of
november to help with employees mental
health now that sounds like it might be
kind of a coincidence right because
students already had off november 2nd
for election day
november 4th for diwali november 5th for
virtual parent-teacher conferences now
the division is going to close november
1st and november 3rd so namely the day
before the election they're going to
close the schools so the teachers can go
out and knock doors that's exactly what
is going on here there's no other way to
read that
okay that is not about the teachers
experiencing mental stress poor teachers
it's about a pretty obvious gambit to
get the teachers to get out there in
canvas votes
as national review points out the
statement could have been designed in a
laboratory to annoy parents it has
everything
short notice the rank prioritization of
teachers over children and
acknowledgement the government employees
failed to do their jobs and absurd
safety is to rationale
oh and also the notion that uh kovin19
is responsible for this all in time for
election day
so virginia is a is a
real bellwether for the democrats if
this thing is even close democrats are
going to be in an utter state of panic
and this is why and terry mcauliffe is
doing a horrible job of this because all
he's been doing is downplaying parent
concerns this entire election cycle how
long can you do this before parents
rebel terry mcauliffe yesterday for
example he was asked about trans
students in sports and instead of taking
the question seriously he suggested that
really nobody should worry about it
because there are very few trans
students in sports which makes no
difference if a competitive boy is
running against girls
we're talking about a a very impotent
amount of students
and why is it why
these children are already going through
such tough challenges
why is it that people are trying to make
their life
so difficult
i go i come from a place you know i got
big ideas we've got to move education
forward
and why are we picking on children
why are we going after children who are
already dealing with so many challenges
why are we not helping them and trying
to lift them up and trying to find an
avenue path so that they can get that
education and feel comfortable
good line of attack here by tara
mcauliffe that if you are a parent who
is concerned about a boy racing against
your girl or wrestling your girl or
being in a bathroom with your girl that
this means that you are somehow a bigot
it's a strong move by him and the bite
administration by the way has taken up
this message at the national level
you'll recall that it became a national
controversy when because of cases like
loudoun county
the doj started talking about how they
were going to investigate parents
as possible domestic terrorists so
merrick garland who was supposed to be
remembered this kind of nonpartisan
figure you remember when barack obama
nominated him for the supreme court and
then he was denied his confirmation
hearings because of senator mcconnell
and the notion was that he was going to
be just you know a completely
non-partisan justice he wasn't going to
be just a hack well turns out he's a
hack garland in testimony yesterday
admits that he initiated that doj
targeting of parents because of a
specific letter from the national school
board association they wrote a letter to
the doj saying that parents were out of
control and like domestic terrorists and
the doj flipped and boom started
investigating parents here's merrick
garland admitting it
first sentence of your memo very first
sentence you said in recent months
there's been a disturbing spike in
harassment intimidation threats of
violence yes when did you first review
the data showing this so-called
disturbing uptick
so i read the letter and we have been
seeing over time threats
i didn't ask you so you read the letter
that's that's your source so let me be
clear this is not a prosecution or is
there some study some effort some
investigation someone did that said
there's been a disturbing uptick or you
just take the words of the national
school board association when the
national school board association which
represents thousands of school boards
and school board members says that there
are these kind of threats
unbelievable so so basically the
national school boards association
because they wish to defend school
boards against parents send a letter to
the doj the doj just says how should we
jump
pretty incredible stuff well terry
mcauliffe is flailing he's already
called in barack obama in order to try
and shore up his campaign and now
unbelievably he's going to try and call
in joe biden which is a giant fail
according to fox news as the polls show
the virginia gubernatorial election neck
and neck between former governor terry
mcauliffe and republican candidate glenn
youngkin president biden is scheduled to
appear with the democrat on the campaign
trail i'm sure that'll be a barn burner
the mcauliffe campaign put out a media
advisory alerting the press that biden
would campaign with mcauliffe in
arlington on tuesday exactly one week
before the election mcauliffe announced
the biden event along with a slew of
other events featuring politicians from
virginia and the nation at large they're
trying to nationalize the campaign
because the more local it is the more
likely mcauliffe loses so they're going
to call in obama they're going to call
in stacy abrams they're calling jamie
harrison and they're going to call in
joe biden
the big problem of course is that joe
biden is not popular in the state of
virginia in fact joe biden is not
popular nearly anywhere the polls right
now show that joe biden is in the low
40s to high 30s in terms of approval
rating so democrats are flailing and you
will see why in just a moment because
joe biden did a town hall presser last
night at town hall with anderson cooper
on cnn it is a disaster area the
president of the united states is not
with us but he has a prescription and
it's more cowbell we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about a
simple fact you are a special individual
and this means you need products that
are made just for you when you order
your morning coffee you don't just say
give me something off the rack instead
you order it the way you want it well
why wouldn't you do that with something
that you are spending like eight hours a
night on namely your mattress helix
sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep
everybody is unique helix knows that so
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and for mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattresses great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers so if you're looking
for a mattress you take the quiz you
order the mattress that you're matched
to and the mattress comes right to your
door shipped for free you don't ever
need to go to a mattress store again
they've got a 10 year warranty you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk free
and they'll pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will helix even
has financing options and flexible
payment plans so a great night's sleep
is never far away head on over to
helixsleep.com ben take that two-minute
sleep quiz that will match you to a
customized mattress that'll give you the
best sleep of your life helix is
offering them to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at
helixsleep.com that is helixleep.com
ben alrighty so you have terry mcauliffe
calling in joe biden for backup that's
going to go extremely poorly joe biden
is not the backup that you need if you
are terry mcauliffe the reason being
if you call joe biden for backup he is
just going to fall over that's all
that's going to be he is going to pop
out of the car and then he's going to
immediately keel over and say a bunch of
impolitic things along the way so he did
this town hall last night with anderson
cooper he is facing down a crisis in
terms of inflation a supply chain crisis
he is facing down a border crisis he
gave up afghanistan completely
destroying whatever possibility of the
future there was for 19 million afghan
women as well as thousands of siv
holders who are still sitting imprisoned
in afghanistan
he's got crises up to wazoo the
president of the united states and so
they sent him out there to stop the
bleeding
the problem is that if you're going to
send someone out there to stop the
bleeding you don't want them
congenitally falling on their own knife
like that's a big mistake and that's
what joe biden did i mean this is just
joe biden has fallen and he cannot get
up so here is uh so joe biden began
we'll start with with what he said
politically and then we'll get to just
the fact that the man is not with us he
is no longer with us
so he began by trying to defend all of
his vaccine mandates
and now here's the thing with people
who've already been vaccinated they're
fine with vaccine mandates because it
doesn't apply to them it's sort of like
when you pull the american public on
taxing the very wealthy most americans
are not very wealthy so they're like
okay it applies to that guy not me so
i'm okay with it but that is not the
question the question is whether it is
high priority for most americans to
force their neighbors to get vaccinated
and whether people who are anti the vast
mandates are very passionate okay and
they are the answer is they are and when
they become an intransigent minority
which is what we have been seeing in
places like southwest airlines or ge
they can shut down the entire economy
they can shut down major businesses
saying we are not going to do something
that you are trying to force us to do
so joe biden's tack here is to say that
if he forces you to get a vaccine
against your will or to vaccinate your
child against your will which is what
they're trying to do with kids 12 to 19
and i guarantee you within three weeks
they're gonna be trying to do this with
kids five to eleven when when joe biden
says this when his take on this is stop
whining about your freedom
this old authoritarian that ain't gonna
go over great
the two things that concern me
one are those who just try to make this
a political issue freedom i have the
freedom to kill you
with my kovic
i mean come on freedom
come on freedom come on okay so i love
the line i have the freedom to kill you
with my covet and nobody wants to kill
anybody else with covet
okay that's why we have the vaccine if
you don't want to die of covet i have a
good solution for you get a vaccine okay
and if you are immunocompromised even if
you take the vaccine that's not going to
be enough you need to protect yourself
with a kn95 you need to be in a more
isolated area period
beyond which even if you're vaccinated
you can now pass the disease we know
this for a fact a huge number of people
who are being infected with kovid
already have been vaccinated
so this baseline so basically what he's
now arguing is that you have no right to
breathe free air
that's what he's arguing because if the
idea is that your mere breath creates
externalities whether you're vaccinated
or non-vaccinated we're talking now
about masking up until the end of time
that is a freedom issue
that's a freedom especially when again
everyone around you has the freedom to
protect themselves as i've said before
what joe biden is basically arguing is
no longer that you must wear a seat belt
what he is arguing is that if somebody
else doesn't wear a seat belt you have
to put a mattress on the front of your
car to catch them when they go flying
through their windshield
and that that is a very different
argument
and not only is it the different
arguments a bad argument coming from the
president of the united
st how did anybody think that this guy's
a good politician is absolutely beyond
me
he is he is thick
he is thick as an unripe coconut it's
it's just it's incredible
okay so moving on from his vaccine
policies which are deeply unlikely to
actually bring an end to the pandemic he
then is asked about rising gas prices
because as it turns out inflation is
crippling a lot of american families
right now the gas prices are out of
control and prices at the shelves are
out of control we're seeing major supply
shortages here is joe biden's wonderful
answer on the gas prices
so there's there there but i i don't i
must tell you i don't have a near-term
answer
there's two things i could do i could go
on the petroleum reserve
and take out and probably reduce re
reduce the price of
gas maybe
18 cents or so a gallon it's still gonna
be above three bucks
and one of the things that i refuse to
have happen because i didn't want
anybody i made a commitment if you pass
the stuff i'm talking about not not one
single penny in tax would go against
anybody making less than 400 grand and
so if you notice this is these highway
bills are not paid for by gas tax
they're paid for by direct expenditures
in other areas so the average person
doesn't have to pay more
so really he's lowering your gas price
by spending a lot of money
get it
no because he's incoherently babbling
like a crazy person
yeah that is the that is the president
of the united states right there well
done everybody
then joe biden is asked about the labor
shortages because we have tremendous
labor shortages in this country we have
10 million open jobs we have millions of
people who aren't going to fill them and
his answer is less than satisfying shall
we say
people are now using this as an
opportunity to say wait a minute do i
want to go back to that 7 hour job
i won't name the particular
restaurant chain but they found out when
they couldn't hire anybody when they
found out they started to pay 20 bucks
an hour
everybody wanna go back to work not a
joke
okay so he's admitting the quiet part
out loud guys he's making my case
he's now admitting that people are
faking about being afraid of kovid
in order to raise their own wages
right that they are relying on
government benefits to try to pry higher
wages out of businesses that are then
going to pass on that cost to consumers
because when you artificially raise the
cost of labor just like if you
artificially raise the cost of any other
input in a product you artificially
raise the price of the product at the
end of the of the supply chain
he said he's admitting it and he's happy
about it right he's happy that he's
artificially increasing the wages of
labor which is resulting in the
inflation that we are seeing right now
he is creating the labor shortages and
he's excited about it he thinks it's a
good thing
that isn't a bug that's a feature of his
plan so if you're worried about
inflation he's promising you more of it
if you're concerned about supply
shortages he's saying it's good that
there are supply shortages because
finally the seven dollar an hour workers
will be getting 25 bucks an hour for the
same work now i have a question for you
do you think that their labor suddenly
became worth 25 an hour or do you think
that price is just gonna get passed on
to you the consumer and to those same
workers by the way because right now
inflation is outpacing wage growth
so his entire plan is a fail but it's
always more cowbell always and forever
more cowbell and then as we'll see in
just a second joe biden decided that he
would talk a little bit about his
economic plans
he suggested for example that um he
would be sleeping alone if he could not
get free community college done which uh
yeah we know jill is really running the
administration joe we get it
so the question was on the the on
community colleges
which which was a big campaign promise
that that you made you talked about that
on campaign trail yeah and i'm going to
get it done
and if i don't i'll be sleeping alone
for a long time
but here's the deal
oh it's the it's the honeymooners now we
all have to pay for community college so
that um he can get some from his wife
apparently that's the uh that's that's
great
yep
terrific joe
also joe says that um
this is i wish you were telling the
truth here he says that we have a
commitment to defend taiwan if china
should militarily attack taiwan this is
immediately walked back by the white
house
i don't want a cold war with china i
just want to make china understand that
we are not going to step back we are not
going to change any of our views so are
you saying that that the united states
would come to taiwan's defense if china
yes we have a commitment to do that
okay so uh then the white house walked
that back like oh well we haven't
changed any status quo no no we don't
offend the chinese so even when joe
biden said something right he says
something wrong
okay and all of this is ancillary to the
major question here which is whether joe
biden's even competent to hold his
office
and the answer of course is that he's
not he is now in
late stage weirdness
right as if you've ever had an elderly
relative who's starting to lose it there
are certain ticks that you see that are
just strange
and joe biden is not
he's non-compost memphis he is he is not
with us
so during the middle of this town hall
joe biden was was talking about the long
beach port and he started asking what he
was doing
i was able to go to the private portion
with 40 percent of all products coming
into the united states of america on the
west coast go through
uh los angeles and uh and uh um uh um
what am i doing here is it long beach
long beach thank you
oh my god
what am i doing here
what am i doing here so remember that
time that rick perry ran for president
and he wanted to name three departments
that he wanted to cut and he only came
up with two and it ended his
presidential campaign here you have the
president of the united states not
remembering the long beach port and
instead of finding something to cover
for just saying and another port in the
area instead he goes what am i what am i
doing here and anderson cooper jumps in
to save him as our media members
typically do then we have this weird
image of joe biden clenching his hands
for no reason as though he has like a a
vest strapped to him and the button in
his fists i don't know like what is he
even doing here here's anderson cooper
ask him a question and the visual is the
president of the united states holding
his arms at 90 degrees
and um and clenching his fist with his
thumbs up as though he is going to clock
in on jeopardy for for the hot round of
questions
about that with just in terms of
inflation because you had told uh us at
a town hall i think it was in july
that the in this was just near-term
inflation the wall street journal
recently talked to like 67
uh financial experts who said that they
they saw high inflation going all the
way or deep into 2022. what is he what
is he doing what is he doing he's just
he's kind of staring off into the
distance and clenching his fists
so one of two things is happening either
the president of the united states is
losing it or
he is cornholio in search for tp for his
bungle those would be the only two
possible options here i i do not know
what the president of the united states
is doing here remember every time trump
did something weird people would like
jump on it and it was it was evidence
that he was crazy and that they needed
to use the constitution to get rid of
him and
what is he doing what does he do and
then he did the weird creepy whispering
routine i don't know who once told joe
biden that it is a good political tactic
to creepily
lean forward and whisper
but that's what horror movie villains do
right that that's where they've got the
victim tied to a chair and they lean
forward and they're like tell me about
your mother
so now you have the president of the
united states doing this here we go
now here's the deal though
you have 55 corporations for example in
the united states of america making over
40 billion
don't pay a cent
not a single little red cent
now i don't care i i'm a capitalist i
hope you can be a millionaire or a
billionaire i not a problem but at least
pay your fair share
don't pay a cent
what's going on with this guy why do you
okay so here's the problem for democrats
the only person who has the leverage to
actually force through joe biden's
crappy plans joe biden is trapped okay
his plans suck and if they are
effectuated then it's going to be bad
for the economy he himself is admitting
he's going to create labor shortages if
his plans actually work it is not going
to create more jobs it's going to create
fewer jobs he's going to be paying
people to stay home he's going to be
paying people not to enter the workforce
but instead to go to community college
to major in lesbian dance theory
this is the president of the united
states actual plan so if he succeeds he
fails and if he fails he also fails and
right now he has no leverage inside his
own
party democratic voters are getting very
upset with joe biden because they feel
like he's not able to use his leverage
but he doesn't have leverage guys
you elected a guy with no leverage
again the only thing that joe biden had
leveraged for was the things like a
bipartisan infrastructure plan but he
has a narrow majority and the
progressives are holding up the deal on
that so he has no leverage he has 50
seats in the senate which means he has
no power and in the house he has a very
narrow majority and a fractious
coalition it turns out that governing is
real tough
and joe biden again he doesn't have the
capacity to actually broker deals
because he is not there he's not there
according to the wall street journal
democrats in washington remain divided
over the scope of president biden's
expansive domestic policy agenda but
their voters both moderates and
progressives have largely rallied around
the push to increase government spending
and say they worry lawmakers will fail
to come to an agreement
several recent polls that boast are
bolstered by interviews with more than
50 democratic voters across six swing
states in recent weeks indicate broad
party support for legislation to expand
social safety net programs and pass
measures aimed at mitigating the effects
of climate change democratic leaders
have proposed paying for well over a
trillion dollars in expanded government
services in part by higher taxes top
democrats acknowledge that would have
been considered too liberal a few years
ago now they say it has broad party
support
but they don't actually have the support
of mansion or cinema according to
politico this morning
neither mansion nor cinema are on board
with
the big spending big taxation plans that
joe biden is pushing
which is a disaster for him
and he he really has no choice i mean
joe manchin came out yesterday and he
said let's pause this thing for six
months according to axios joe manchin
said quote we shouldn't do it at all
apparently bernie had said let's spend
six trillion dollars
and manchin said how about zero
and then manchin said this will
contribute to inflation we've already
passed the american rescue plan we've
just passed the infrastructure bill and
you know pause for six months
yup
joe said i'm comfortable with nothing
so
joe and by the way joe manchin has no
incentive here
mansion yesterday said i'm a centrist
deal with it
you know the fact of the matter is that
he is from west virginia a state that
went for donald trump by something like
40 points the fact that there's a
democrat from west virginia in the
senate is a
is a weirdness of history in and of
itself mansion knows that and he knows
the minute that he votes for this bad
biden bill he's done as a senator he
will not win re-election in west
virginia here he is basically
acknowledging that
anything that was ever said that we've
ever talked about if i'm an
embarrassment to my
my democrat colleagues my caucus uh the
president being the democrat the heat of
the democratic party chuck schumer and
all them and i said me being a
moderate centrist democrat if that
causes you a problem let me know and i'd
switch to be an independent but i'd
still be caucusing with democrats
both cinema and mansion have basically
said that they are not in favor of
massive tax increases those seem to be
largely off the table at this point
but meanwhile it's such a divide inside
the democratic party and normally the
president bridges those divides right
the president brings everybody together
inside his own party not so with regard
to president biden and and this is
leaving these so-called moderate
senators not knowing which way to turn a
good sort of bellwether for this is
senate majority leader chuck schumer so
he is the senate majority leader he has
been re-elected to his senate position
several times by wide margins now he's
running so scared of the aoc wing of the
party that he announced he was endorsing
india walton to be mayor of buffalo
giving the winner of the democratic
primary a crucial boost only days before
early voting begins again in her race
against mayor byron brown
schumer's decision gave walton backing
from a centrist democrat at a time when
other figures like governor kathy hokel
and representative brian higgins buffalo
refused to take sides in a battle
between an upstart primary winner and a
four-term incumbent who's waging a
write-in campaign that's because the
india walton's like an actual
honest-to-god socialist
so schumer endorsed her because he was
afraid that he'd be outflanked by aoc
and then walton would go ahead and win
the election so now he is feeding the
alligator they're all feeding the
progressive alligator
because normally the person who would be
able to stand up to the alligator is the
president of the united states and he is
too busy sleeping and taking his early
afternoon nap before watching the rerun
of matlock
so weld on everybody
now meanwhile
we have the amazing spectacle this
should be the top story in the country
it is not however the nih has now
admitted to funding a gain of research
function gain and function research in
wuhan
okay isn't that a major story we'll get
to that in just one second first let's
talk about the simple fact your gas
prices are up and joe biden knows it you
know it everybody knows it well right
now you can get an incredible app
if you buy gas you need it it's called
get upside my listeners are making up to
25 cents for every gallon of gas every
time they fill up just download the free
get upside app in the app store or
google play right now you can use promo
code shapiro you get a bonus 25 cents
per gallon on your first fill up that's
up to 50 cents cash back don't pay full
price at the pump anymore get cash back
using get upside you download the app
for free use promo code shapiro you get
up to 50 cents a gallon cashback on your
very first tank of gas which means a lot
to people right now given the price of
gas some people who drive a lot are
making as much as two to three hundred
bucks a month in cash back there's no
catch the cash back gets added directly
to your bank account so you can cash out
any time your bank account paypal or an
e-gift card for amazon or other brands
just download the free get upside app
use promo code shapiro to get up to 50
cents per gallon cash back on your very
first tank that is promo code shapiro go
check them out right now get the get
upside app and use that promo code you
get 50 cents per gallon cashback on your
first tank and then beyond that 25 cents
back pretty i mean it's just saving
money so i'm not sure exactly what
you're waiting for go check out the app
right now it's get upside and use the
promo code shapiro to get started we'll
get to more of the news in just one
second first big announcement so you saw
the story this week that espn had
basically fired allison williams this
super talented sideline reporter college
football basketball they fired her
because she was trying to get pregnant
and didn't want to take a coven 19
vaccine so they said fine you're out of
a job well she's not out of a job any
longer we have hired her here at daily
wire and we are pumped about it she's
going to be bringing us excellent sports
content we need your help to do this
kind of stuff to help bring people in
who've been thrown out into the cold by
the woca culture go help us out at
dailywire.com
subscribe use code do not comply at
checkout for 25 off we're basically
uncanceling everybody that hollywood and
the leftist machine is canceling and so
we need your help to do that allison
williams has joined the daily wire we
are super excited for her sports
coverage and we're excited to slap espn
in the face frankly dailywire.com
subscribe code do not comply for 25 off
join the fight also the truth is hard to
come by if you're listening to the
legacy media that's why we've taken
matters into our own hands we have a
brand new morning podcast morning wire
it's been topping the apple and spotify
charts since its release it's the only
daily podcast that values your time and
the truth and while we are working
overtime to bring you the news you need
to know we need your help to keep the
facts trending toward number one so
please subscribe start listening now to
morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts leave a
five star review if you like what you
hear you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
and meanwhile the biggest story of the
day that you won't see on the network
news a top nih official admitted in a
wednesday letter that u.s taxpayers
funded gain of function research on back
coronaviruses in wuhan and revealed that
ecohealth alliance the u.s nonprofit
that funneled nih money to the wuhan
institute of virology was not
transparent about the work it was doing
now shouldn't this be the biggest
bombshell in america that your federal
your your dollars were funding the wuhan
institute of virology to perform gain of
function research on bat coronaviruses
now remember the lab league theory was a
conspiracy theory it was labeled such by
all of the elitists in our society it
was labeled as such by social media you
weren't supposed to discuss it it was
very bad it was anti-chinese racism to
even mention it and if you mentioned
that the nih
under the auspices of people like dr
fauci was funding gain of function
research if you did that this meant that
you were some sort of crazy conspiracy
theorist well now the nih is admitting
it
and now gain of function research for
those who don't know is where you take a
virus that is not transmittable
to humans and you make it transmissible
to humans this is in sort of the
colloquial sense the very technical
sense is where you make a virus that is
transmissible more transmissible so what
fouchy had been arguing for a while here
is that it does not gain a function
research to take a back coronavirus and
make it applicable to humans hey that is
a distinction without a difference that
is idiotic
okay so you'll remember that he had a
knockdown drag out fight in the senate
in which he admits that the chinese
could have used money for gain of
function research
you gave them money and you said don't
do gain to function research correct and
they said we won't
correct
and you have no way of knowing
whether they did or not except you trust
them is that right
well we generally always trust the
grantee to do what they say and you look
at the results have you ever had a
grantee lie to you
i cannot guarantee that a grantee has
not lied to us
because you never know
you never know well i mean i think it's
a pretty good indicator that you
shouldn't be giving money to the chinese
government
in a letter to representative james
comer republican of kentucky lawrence
tabik of the nih cites a quote limited
experiment that was conducted to test if
quote spike proteins from naturally
occurring back coronaviruses circulating
in china were capable of binding to the
human h2 receptor in a mouse model the
lab mice infected with the modified bad
virus became sicker than those infected
with the unmodified bad virus
that revelation vindicates rand paul who
got into heated exchanges with national
institute of allergy and infectious
disease director anthony fauci during
his may and july testimonials before
congress over that gain of function
question at the second hearing paul
accused fouchy of misleading congress by
denying the united states had funded
gain of function projects at the muhan
institute of virology
in keeping with fauci's refusal to use
gain of function terminology tabik also
avoids the term though the work he
describes match describes matches its
commonplace definition precisely
a previously unpublished ecohealth grant
proposal filed with the nia id obtained
by the intercept had already exposed
that almost six hundred thousand dollars
of the total grant to the wuhan
institute of virology was for research
designed to make viruses more dangerous
and or infectious
richard ebright biosafety expert
professor of chemistry and chemical
biology at rutgers university had
previously rebutted fauci's claim that
the nih has not ever and does not now
fund gain of function research in the
wuhan institute of virology as quote
demonstrably false
ebright told national review the
nih-financed work at the wiv epitomizes
the definition of gain of function
research which deals with enhanced
potential pandemic pathogens or those
pathogens resulting from the enhancement
of the transmissibility and or virulence
of a pathogen
apparently tabic also revealed that
ecohealth failed to comply with its
reporting requirements under the grant
ecohealth was required to submit to a
secondary review in the event of certain
developments that might increase the
danger associated with the research so
when wuhan researchers successfully
bound a natural bat coronavirus to a
human ace2 receptor in mice they were
supposed to inform the nih and then they
didn't
okay that is a full-scale disaster area
for the nih and for anthony fauci
because now you have to ask okay so they
took a background virus they bound into
a human h2 receptor we're supposed to
believe that this then naturally
occurred in the wild that it wasn't a
lab leak and that sort of research that
we were funding had nothing to do with
the death of millions of people around
the world
should give us a different perspective
on whether we ought to be doing business
with china
should certainly give us a different
perspective on whether the experts ought
to be trusted on this stuff when they
have been lying to us consistently
you want to talk about the blowout of
institutional trust
you have dr anthony fauci presiding over
an agency that was in fact funding gain
of function research at the wuhan
institute of virology now according to
these new communications
lying to the american people about it
and then proceeding to take every
possible position on every possible
issue throughout the pandemic and then
when people have doubts they're like
well i don't know why you don't trust us
you need to trust us okay so fauci's new
push in the push of this administration
is to get kids vaccinated
now if you think for one solitary second
that the push to get kids vaccinated
ends with your kids unmasking in school
you're out of your mind it ain't gonna
happen the reason it ain't gonna happen
is because as we already know the virus
is still infectious even if you are a
vaccinated person the cdc has been
urging you to continue to mask up and
rochelle walensky said over the weekend
that if your kid gets a vaccine then
your kid should continue to mask up in
perpetuity forever
so what exactly is the strong case for
kids getting vaccinated
well thatchy says we have to stop kids
from getting the disease at all zero
covet is not a thing guys zero code is
not a thing the reason you get
vaccinated is you don't get hospitalized
or die the chances of being hospitalized
or dying as a child are lower than your
chances of being hospitalized or dying
if you're a vaccinated adult
in the vast majority of cases here is dr
anthony fauci trying to promote kids
getting again i'm not saying kids
shouldn't get vaccinated i'm saying that
the governmental mandates that are sure
to follow this and they will come are
utterly out of line with both the
science and with basic human decency
here is dr anthony fauci
talking about kids ages 5 to 11 and
that's something that will be considered
very soon and perhaps given an emergency
used authorization very soon how
concerned are you that parents are going
to stand in the way of children getting
these vaccines
well i hope not i mean that's one of the
reasons why we want to make sure that we
we outreach to the parents with trusted
messengers particularly some of the most
trusted messengers are the family
pediatrician
who most parents have a good deal of
confidence in and we're trying to get
people to realize it is for the benefit
of the children as well as for the
entire family unit to get the child
vaccinated the vaccinations and the
vaccines in question are highly highly
effective and safe so there's really no
reason not to
okay i mean a few reasons not to are the
kids are basically safe from
hospitalization and death from covid
without the vaccine we have no
longitudinal data the entire study
sample size was about 2 300 kids
myocarditis only appears in one in 9 000
kids so the sample size isn't even big
enough for you to determine what the
alternative
symptoms are
we don't again we
it's one thing to risk the risk the the
possible
cost of the vaccine downstream for
people who have a higher level of risk
of hospitalization or death when you're
talking about kids most of whom are
asymptomatic you have to make a pretty
strong case as to why kids should get
vaccinated and the case that they might
infect adults i'm sorry this is endemic
this is endemic now it is in fact
probably more likely that adults are
going to in fact kids most of the
outbreaks that we've seen in schools are
coming from teachers to the kids not the
other way around
okay and but but anthony fauci has to
push this and so he's also been pushing
the notion that for example
the spike that we are seeing in britain
right now is due to kids right so he
said this quote
what they are seeing is spread among
children which for the most part at
least 50 is without symptoms but
children are then spreading it to
members of the family so they're seeing
people get infected so right now they're
re-examining what their policy is going
to be about vaccinating children right
she's blaming a current uk spike on the
unvaccinated kids except for the fact
that the people who are being
hospitalized and dying are unvaccinated
adults and or vaccinated adults who had
the vaccines a long time ago and happen
to be old
right that's where the real danger lies
but instead of focusing on the adults
we're going to go after the kids why you
would trust these people i just don't
understand i really don't understand
what they have done to earn your trust
so if you talk to your family
pediatrician and your family
pediatrician recommends the shots listen
to your family pediatrician but why you
trust anthony fauci on a blanket level
here is beyond me and why you trust
political actors is really beyond me so
you have jerry and adler for example
yesterday in the house they were having
some sort of committee meeting and jerry
nadler starts calling out the
republicans who are not masking on the
committee
i would remind all members that guidance
from the office of attending physicians
states that face coverings are required
for all meetings in enclosed spaces such
as committee hearings
except when you are recognized to speak
and that means you jim and marjorie and
matt and a lot of other people i can't
recognize because of distance
etc so
please everyone observe that rule
okay my favorite part of this is that
literally half of the room is unmasked
literally half the room also i don't
know why the rule is that you get to
unmask when you speak if we're going to
be scientifically proper about this when
you're speaking is when you should wear
the mask that's when you're expelling
spit it's when you're aerosolizing the
virus
but this is all political it's all
political and it drives me up a damned
wall there is no consistency coming from
the cdc there's no consistency coming
from the fda there's no consistency in
what they hope is the pathway forward
from the pandemic because we all know at
this point it's endemic
the only thing you can do if you're
concerned is vaccinate yourself if
you're concerned for your child go ahead
and vaccinate your kid and if you're not
don't and that's the end of this we are
done but not according to our public
officials who maintain control they're
in their sclerotic pathetic hands
the more control you choose to give to
more on politicians the more control you
choose to give to overarching
authoritarian authoritarian bureaucrats
the more you deserve to be controlled
and if you believe that they can save
you from disease or save you from
poverty or save you from the
vicissitudes of life you are out of your
damned mind you're crazy the only thing
that can save you from these things is
good individual decision making which is
why i've encouraged individuals to get
vaccines if they're in any way
vulnerable and it's also why i say that
you need to perform individual risk
assessment because when you allow
everybody else to control your life it
is worse for you and it is worse for
everybody else already we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content first you can't forget to end
your week by checking out the andrew
clavin show drew's show is every friday
he's got an exciting evening planned for
you as always head on over to
dailywire.com 7 pm eastern 6 pm central
tune in also a quick reminder we are
very excited that allison williams is
joining the daily wire i'm very pumped
about that i think that it's a good move
for us i think it's a good move for her
and more importantly i think it's a slap
in the face to the vaccine
authoritarianism you're seeing at places
like disney where they are forcing
people to lose their jobs if they don't
do what disney wants so if you want to
support that head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe today help us
out promo code do not comply for 25 off
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavo
wiedowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica crans the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin